c'est loin des lieux du drame chez elle
que la communauté atticamet de Manouane
a choisi d'honorer la mémoire de Joyce
et jacuan je reste ma nièce
on est en 2022 bientôt en 2023 puis il y
a encore des gens qui souffrent même
après Joy c'est pas terminé
ils ont fait une pancarte pour Joyce
mais aussi pour Jessica parce qu'ils
m'ont dit c'est pas juste que à l'ipos à
maman
deux ans se sont écoulés depuis le décès
de la bien-aimée de Carole Dubé deux ans
consacrés à donner vie à son héritage
immense
pour le mémoire de Joyce c'est un bon
moyen aussi d'envoyer le message
c'est pas régulier non on a entendu la
main au gouvernement avec le principe de
jazz pour lui proposer comment on
devrait travailler le gouvernement n'a
pas écouté a fait la source d'oreille
depuis deux ans d'ailleurs cette journée
aurait pu être l'occasion d'un premier
vrai tête à tête entre le conjoint de
Joyce et schauan et François Legault
c'est plutôt Yann Lafrenière le ministre
sortant des Affaires autochtones qui a
répondu présent
tout était réglé au camp de Tours pour
que le premier soit là ici en communauté
c'est impossible le Premier ministre
sortant à tout de même défendu son bilan
on a posé des gestes on embauché
l'adjoint à la présidente du 6 on a
embauché des agents de liaison pour
faire la liaison entre les employés de
l'hôpital de Joliette et les membres de
la communauté on a donné une formation à
tous les employés à l'hôpital de
Joliette et moi on me dit que la
situation c'est beaucoup amélioré à
l'hôpital de Joliette après deux ans
réinsérer après tout ce qui s'était
passé à l'Assemblée nationale que ce
soit tous levé de manière très sensible
pour tout le monde qu'on se soit rendu
beaucoup plus loin la famille est bien
déterminée à garder le combat de Joyce
et Shark one et sa mémoire vivante une
poursuite pour tenter d'obtenir
réparation sera déposé demain ici Amélie
Demaret Radio-Canada manoise